it is a Southern Nevada Gem and during
the holidays
the hot spot warm chocolate drinks sweet
treats Ethel M of course is what I'm
talking about that's right family
friendly fun last minute gifts of course
and sweet treats as you mentioned it's
Candace Charles AKA Candace yes live
over at flm in Henderson this morning
Candice good morning to you
good morning you two good morning folks
my Willy Wonka and Chocolate Factory
dreams are coming true and I'm joined by
Tammy Joe French and actually that's how
she got her start here at Ethel M
Chocolates she's a chocolatier she's a
chocolate Entertainer she loves
chocolate and she's here to talk to us
about the one and only famous hot
chocolate okay tell us a little bit
about what we're going to be making here
so we have a new flavor it's our
peppermint hot chocolate okay so we have
our double hot chocolate and we add
peppermint sprinkles it sounds delicious
the whipped cream on okay so do it to
this side yeah and then all the way into
the center and how much is this and the
small is going to be five dollars nice
and some change by 42 and then the large
is seven I'm just gonna go crazy with
the sprinkles yes and then you just
sprinkle on top absolutely yes that
looks okay okay right next to us we have
a few gifts that you guys can get here
last minute holiday gifts when you guys
are looking and these are actually under
25 tell us a little bit about it so we
have the three boxes are 50 dollars each
and then we also have if you want like a
bigger box we have the cactus garden
with the Christmas lights that one is 40
and then we have the double layer home
for the holidays which is sixty dollars
nice and people can come through here
and walk through and see the work and
also go to the cactus garden for just a
dollar the tour is free tell us really
quickly what's a good time for people to
come down here I would say the earlier
the better try to get here at 5 45 and
get in line so that way you can get easy
into the garden really fits nice nice
thank you Tammy Joe well this looks
delicious and you guys gonna taste it
for you really quickly
oh Heather you're completely right it's
so so good you guys can come on down
here and check this all out yourself the
shop the factory is here in Henderson
got to cover all the details on our
website newsnow.com for now I'm Candace
Charles live from ethelm Factory and
chocolates here all right it is the best
tasty stuff Candace thank you very much